so-called libertarian republican senator
rand paul
is now calling for republicans to
boycott
coca-cola i know i know
why is he doing this well because
coca-cola expressed an opinion
that the georgia voter suppression bill
is bad
here is rand paul saying it on fox news
on sunday take a look well my point is
yeah if they want to boycott us why
don't we boycott them
this is the only thing that will teach
them a lesson if coca-cola wants to only
operate in democrat states and wants
only democrats to drink coca-cola
god love them we'll see how they do when
half of the country quits drinking
coca-cola
when half the country quits using delta
now of course half the country
won't quit flying delta and half the
country
won't quit drinking coca-cola partially
because people are addicted to coca-cola
but partially because these
culture issues only play big in
some circles and most americans don't
care about them
here's another one republican senate
minority leader
just still gives me great pleasure to
say senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell
he says corporations should stay out of
politics
it's unbelievable i know take a look and
i found it completely discouraging to
find a bunch of
corporate ceos getting in the middle of
politics my advice to the corporate ceos
of america is to stay out of politics
so the question for mitch mcconnell is
should they also stay out of politics by
not making any political donations
because
if money is speech you're really
speaking
either way and later mitch mcconnell was
asked about her and he said oh no no no
no i'm not talking about political
donations but think about that i mean
think about the
the hypocrisy if money is speech
when companies make political donations
they are speaking
they are giving political opinions by
donating money
to one or the other or both parties or
neither
but he says corporations need to shut up
except the money which is speech
according to them that doesn't need to
stop um
these people are the biggest hypocrites
at every single level
and look look at the number of double
standards that there are
when it's chick-fil-a with a political
statement they like
it's speech corporations are entitled to
speak
they shouldn't be punished for having
opinions the people saying boycott
chick-fil-a are the ones that are in the
wrong
when it's coca-cola with an opinion they
don't like
the view now becomes corporate ceos
should
shut up and stay out of politics but
not when it comes to political donations
where money is speech
in that case mitch mcconnell wants them
very much
in politics donating to him
they're against cancel culture they're
against boycotts
when it's of fox news advertisers but
then they cheer
when fox news runs a crawl with a list
of companies that took the wrong
position on voting laws
which we're going to look at in the next
segment who is more pathetic and
hypocritical than these people now i'm
going to make a statement today
i am committed to not
changing my soda consumption in any way
as a result of this
i have not had soda for like a decade
other than the occasional foreign coke
yes
foreign coke sweetened not with corn
syrup but with sugar
i've probably had five foreign cokes in
latin america and europe over the last
10 years
otherwise i am committed to not making
any changes one way or the other to my
non-existent soda consumption as a
result of this now just one other really
funny thing
about this entire thing they might be
saying
boycott coke without actually having any
intention or plan to do it case in point
new picture of donald trump at his new
office
and his new desk in florida or florida
depending on your your preference
new picture has been published if you
look at it carefully
you can actually see a coke bottle
hidden behind donald trump's phone so
even
their stated boycotts uh they may not
abide by
because they actually just like the
product how ridiculous are these people
completely and totally pathetic
abandoning their stated values
they don't really care it's all about
avoiding policy
and fighting cultural issues and fox
news is now in on it too let's talk
about that next